and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't lie can be read and you can be on
anime i you everything yeah like at you
anything hurt you
you only know murder thank you only the
luggage i buy everything room you could
be the most beautiful few did their have
to say I've been working so hostile baby
you know I I was just running it I got
my kid
my son's angry we have will and
permitted alternator left
everything we do in society is being a
business because all the women money
Jessica Dallas T to make me in Paris
Brad butan going up right now 79 is
going up right now I need a hottest in
the club right now
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go to sleep an update what my socks are
like oldest one sleeps and a few
snapshots hope will not blink and I'm
trying to be Spencer with the arches I
can't but I college I used to hold it
all to all the pigeons up paint we
obtain in our focus with brown regular
water giant now set the Box in your
sweetie you wanna get a break just all
in a be sore at my brother by the way
come with me
my name's John gives so evacuated with
the way time is aligned with the divine
I never abducted I can break the cycle
never break the titles now rocking with
the great we waking up today Vic travels
all around the globe the silence is the
canvas guide you got to stroke covered
in the blood of Jesus lead me to that
kind of yo the purpose red stream which
is the perfect Esther when I get to
heaven happy with the work in Hell yet
ruslan guy with the name most
mispronounced mister nautical are going
in but they miss the now system a
passion and drive contained in the body
alive Prophet Elias Baba autumn rhythm
now
yelling for the theme lovely husband
indicate killed nothing dragging on the
field
something on my own still hungry an
adult I feel lovely I like to lure my
poor kids what they think once again I'm
introduced in the corner and the new
leaving for the coast for the pool we
buff against Purdue we mean but I mean
that's my old horn that I'm teaching if
you knew someone told it it's instrument
so good but now the probably spotted my
body mouth
apply to the life with a party if you
kick me out so who's the crowd I'll make
you smile plus when our Brahman
circumstance you never seen like
freeways change back for the second time
second line and recognize attacking our
passive ticket a pigeon surpassed to me
and it always changing after so much
more a dream that can is the difference
of eternity it seen and in argue what it
means to be a dream up right there is it
make your cleaner flying with a team of
product mean poets we like to pioneer
the code is come get you a sip because
this Rainer taking off to attract Jill
and aggressive villainous take one of
venomous it unlike the zombie I could
sign it on that minimalistic trying to
take it back design people in the street
stop I just want to do something else
with it to get sitting on my hands never
part of the plan
take a leap of faith and father Paul and
Barnabus plan the agreement it changed
the world effect you couldn't understand
it maybe it wasn't clear
maybe I made it foggy maybe I was just a
weirdo
[Music]
yeah comma drop he see the commissar
then hit it retreats Peter Thomas I draw
more keep snake charmer calm instead of
Jesus Freak part is no kamikaze guide
supposed to rob willfully to read get a
wig pull a monkey a lot of slavery
take your time likely see ticket that so
make sure you let believe reward
officially going weed reppin witness her
now pressure makes diamonds we adopt us
what your firm Alvin Tony was turned out
when you cut down the actors up and put
the cartridge Orion approach to the
blood burger so uh I'm a married man on
talk to come abroad pol boy must be
bummers mamasan your County resident but
catch me at the promenade
we will overthrow this boat like a
common stock I'm the only black John and
no before taxes wait there's oh [ __ ]
causing all commotion when I'm toasting
what my little brothers little games
coming sugar to the don't go sin I think
I can't keep it in the same try Jules
Peter panting sure the captain look with
the look at this third Frida stands in
fact another prize winner who the heck
broke the size of the rotator pain tape
is a minister I'm rather lame
evangelizing and dismantling the
different points if you sing the blues
no more hampering
what's the secret sauce Peter formula
careful rings are these baby boomers
late bloomer stop dancer emancipation
the armor I compared to take the home in
my speech when I thought the harmonies
read like a social part in my reach we
go live long
I mean Kimmie's whiskey can we get back
or leeches we're in Savannah good point
yo Christie no fortitude and fire
working inside the person that deserve
an efficient but emergency repair
decided to serve those don't gotta sell
me to get off but it bothers open
depending upon Apocrypha coming around
the corner with the time for they are
really on you don't wanna be is on his
way to talk and appeasement playing with
the car simply get proper them drink
junk
[Music]
yeah hotel room always work yeah yeah
Alan California counting on my blessings
only 24 with a multi-million dollar
attention off my catalog that's cause
I'm a dog like cheeto cuz I'm on and I
got more songs than the Beatles oh
that's a stretch yeah I guess but you
get the gist laughing at the skeptics
cuz I always knew I get to swish family
knowing Boogaloo that's not Leah about
it because you come in the game the
quicker you go out it darling really
bout [ __ ] y'all ain't got no substance
yeah I heard you little viral song some
fun dumb [ __ ] someone my [ __ ] your
seasonal rapper you will [ __ ] the world
[ __ ] to believe it you
don't hit my phone with stupid [ __ ]
that's not why I gave you my new number
you stupid [ __ ] the legion drop you I
don't have but I want to I'm just
trimming the fat haters grounded in
doubt meanwhile I'm swimming in cash I
was never cool y'all don't try to link
up now because my train left the station
but it's a Brinks truck now I switch up
Styles like I was dating by doing timing
to hate on the truth I'm calling my name
on the roof of hip hop and breaking on
through to the other side like Jim
Morrison guzzling Jam wondering if I
drink more than him scary thought I got
the juice like Barry Bonds I ain't
trying to blend in like white kids with
berries on your bacon than these rappers
who keep trying to clean in d-major the
Nexus millions behind you you're not in
to get offended and I got you by hip-hop
collar cook Ruby told me that only a hit
dog Hollis top dollars but they pay me
for the flows nowadays we free women
free clothes nowadays all we got is time
so my time is my investor I'm single so
I save money and live better yeah I need
my plaques advanced Teldar I Double A
underrated and overlooked yes but never
underpaid move off the web like Peter
Parker went from flying 32 after private
just getting charted this is my
departure used to think it was delayed
till I let go of the wheel and let my
faith fly my plane when I started taking
off
Nereus in my bank account manifested
everything became what I would think
about twenty thousand dollars for the
show is what I'm making now and I sister
guarantees before the merchant Lee in
Greece and it's only accurate -
yesterday
I'm staying Lewis with my whole climb
back to LA that's what I'm
I've been all over studios my gym is my
family up I'm all shoulders I fall
forwards I don't ever fail I went from
TAS room bills to 50 bands I'm getting
better mail every cell I make I keep a
hundred percent I put in overtime
because momma 100 index as low balling
no calling my phone I'm in grief so
precious at my neck at GNC I'm a freak
to my mom around the world my bucket
list is ever-changing women wet on
arrival [ __ ] chicks is better famous
I'm poppin from the south side to the
school dance this time last year
I'm applied for food stamps yeah and now
it's Michelin star restaurants in every
country new koala the only one in the
whole place below 40 with two climbers I
love the way I did it ain't nobody tell
me [ __ ] cuz they nobody make me hot and
they nobody make me rich hope that cash
that your classrooms been provision for
your taxes to the IRS is watching Buffy
could be problematic you should shell
like you've seen some money before I
can't date a chick that's never left the
country before but take your bra put
your hair up put my hoodie on eyes are
windows to the soul
y'all stay put me on I got you baby
every morning like I'm Alma grass and
your body in my hand is my next collab
I'm texting back but not enough because
my life is poppin you have from do to do
than club the club I'm island-hopping
reminiscing back before I have one track
back when I will put that half a gram
and blunt rap but me and boogies got so
hot before graduation I think I got too
high don't remember graduating that's
been thinking [ __ ] diplomas I got flax
now used to celebrate a thousand plays
look
back now I realize that the journey is
everything the ain't no destination man
the journey is everything looking back I
realize the journey is that we've been
ain't no destination man the journey is
done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and I don't ever stop do you see the
Danny buck got the way to lay their eyes
on the stage the people here but I did
not
maybe I'm reading his duties or the bulk
of people being I wonder does he think I
maybe my life easily set a bitching like
only protecting to a mountainside drunk
you gotta take a ride with the gonna go
midnight put these closer signifies man
I gotta turn the tables my novel la
pages page you got to pop out of this
game but I suggested a man plays sake
but you've gotta be right looks a lot
like a big ghost a choir who's dating
you like the spider but I'm so [ __ ]
high Barack could never be
[Music]
we complain about where we're going to
go to King complain about every [ __ ]
cities I was panicking all the time
about you won't ever be the landfill go
and keep his line if you were one happy
- don't be obscene - Leslie have to fly
favorites Kyle and I look up in your
eyes I can see you gonna drive alive
dude it's not Jackson had a sexy babe
look at me every day Danny Manning
didn't play but I guess that just got
you know thank you
everything that I don't got it family to
me more when I was late I could close
the door yeah with that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pardon my melody but I discover too long
that me promethazine I need someone to
lean on swear not to trust again that's
it my innocence I bought a look too much
that's just my innocence
I've inserted into words I concur with
the backup song but the worst is behind
I'll be fine as soon as we all know the
tapes were crashing the way too hot
exchanger trapped in the snake curse
crisis experts all I can taste first all
in the day's football threes all got a
case worth crashing wait how did you
taste are trapped in this tanker spongy
legs burst balling it thanks for all of
the tape bird why did my negligence but
I just don't give a [ __ ]
sucking my head again club money or open
up restricted by a to me but I needed to
breathe was on every night that's it
fantasy just wanna have a baby skin and
my legacy flirting with Mandela peace
losing mean they can't let Indian from
mocking I thought she really was never
sleeping what is left but a minute long
go go go
I'm in surgeons words that hinder with
the factor
but the worst is behind I'll be fine
together for three long gonna taste for
fashion wait we parted to taste our
trust and estate currency
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
always been the wise guy I was for the
hot side looking back a hot side yes
give and every night night never really
felt like the right time feel right now
I was of the night life lost in the moon
like ever since I signed up honestly
tonight today what a nice look babe look
at stocks that could be yeah the waters
the mark was it enough
you know who you are gotta just walk for
the Money two for the show three three
three nine zero one Fulani to my bros 3
3 3 darcy on the love smoking weed where
the mountain peaks just a better viewed
in the balcony join me in my Odyssey I
hear good music when obsolete
that's just everything with the
conjuring caught up in a revolution
we're the creators of our destiny yet
after movement set me free and just sell
me weed baby paths to do I need a funky
being in a soulful vibe yes son you get
my mom moving I'm just warming up at
night an object you don't want to see
meet you
top legs almost off man for just go
crazy low kilo so cool don't go til I
get that oh so raikou try my wiggling
guilty country though that's a guilty
conscious to being honest I'm always
making bank deposits save yourselves to
the saved it mama it's a crazy journey
for a starving artist having hard to
harm myself
I mean who got me but myself
I'm limitless unlimited I'm infinite you
can't match the dents and did I mention
this I'm paying close attention to earth
to shifting our spirits a-lifted the
system is twisted the months that are
gifted just think of the children that
logic invention the Ross [ __ ] well I'll
get evicted with God as my witness I'm
closing my eyes and I pray to the one
that created the world that we live in
for all the wrongs I committed I always
been the wise guy I was the hot looking
like a hot side town you can have
everything night never really felt like
the right time so right now always the
night like lost in the moon like never
see the Sun shines out honestly nice day
what a nice one babe wicked stocks that
could be yeah the world is the market
was it enough
know who you are God doesn't just walk
for the Money two for the show three
three three nineteen emo waffle my honey
to my brows three three threes on see on
the love then slower young fall still
asourian tall and everybody knows
somebody knows and what everybody knows
you know what to go running you right
with God but he never answers my calls
maybe I wasn't praying it all that maybe
I was just doing it wrong back to the
bait
wrapping in the bass different situation
little innovation mister Civil War we
civil no more as of late like I messed
over in the ringer box
I'm Johnny Cash baby new do you desire I
got a lot of catfish you got a lot of
ads then I can tell you a fighter let it
burn let it burn like us I got GERD as
bad indigestion if we need eased and I
get no sleep shoulda listened to the
doctor I said mama I listen to the doc
now I was talking about dragging
nowadays everybody wanna talk but they
got something to say when up comes out
when they move the lips just a bus
gibberish yeah [ __ ] I think
they forgot about that [ __ ] I can't
forget about me I was in the watch out
always with the hot lights looking back
at last night now you've and everything
night never really felt like the right
down hill right now almost of the night
life lost in the moon I never see the
sunshine now I'm sitting like damn what
a nice time babe when we get the stocks
that could be yeah the world is the mark
was it enough
know who you are God doesn't just work
for the Money two for the show three
three three Nardini mouth one for my
honey do my brows three three threes on
see on the love scene I love their queen
friends and own enemy I need to be
smartly behind the evil thing that I've
seen known each other's got need nobody
don't need a wife I need to mohabbat
alarms down eyes watching the sunrise
imma lively nice time nothing we can do
it I seen the nozzle lows in between I
press a note man to me I need some peace
modely behind the things that I've seen
known each other I've got me no I don't
need a lock ring no need nobody knows
Oh Robert you are - I brought to the Sun
I'm alive and I'm down my god can't keep
risking assets least of all you
what are you blocking my transfer now
kill any one of these guys walk through
fire
[Music]
are you telling me you're willing to
sacrifice that in order to fly around
with a bunch of snake eaters in the off
chance you're going to find your friend
in the middle of a desert
[Music]
I only have one thing to say to you come
God's pants yeah I'll make a magic
you've been back was I handle heavy made
it head I'll take it magic
I'll make it magic you was bad was it no
information in retro action you has been
popular faster you stay stagnant I had
to have it made it happen
yeah I'm so steadily I think that's the
head and his loving teeth equipment you
bet W better with a team like glue to me
hey stuck on what's been done improving
see I'm saying truth I'm trying to move
like Tarantino did with Django I never
learned that ain't no no never learn to
aim low time chiming and do with the
future fu [ __ ] you bang [ __ ] yeah like
why the [ __ ] would you bang oh you day
was I had to have it made it I'm taking
back I'm making mine G yeah you move the
bag with there's no inspiration in retro
whack Shane you ask I'm moving faster
you say you say me I had to have it made
it happen
yeah don't play things no no make a lane
oh you got one person only teaming
real snow fade away no nove awaiting the
onus this book is gonna go straight to
the stain them they said of Fame them
I'm totally shows don't go to menu face
- yelling dress you know follow two ugly
Garrity and they hang though we in Milan
like um platoon she had a pain so I'm
making Bank
yeah I'm making magic yeah I'm making
magic you walking back was I had to have
it made ahead use this bag with it no
inspiration in retro waxing you Hansen
I'm moving fast you say you saying I had
to have it made it happen
yeah okay what's really good go hop in
cussing and coughing if you feeling like
I thought that was really good go ahead
and hop in Qatar in and talking it you
feel it yeah yeah trying to do know all
but it does no good mean I wish I
couldn't get duty trying to stay on
track minutes harder the rocky the
correct is if I was true to you men we
all make mistakes
I'm sorry they don't know life away and
it turns out despite the games we can
all sound bright like lightning way
still ain't thinking twice about still
make your major move and move the page
about my angel yeah that's the my and I
do no harm but it does no good man I
wish I could you do kind of stay on
track Minotaur is the racket the cranky
the time for sleep you remember y'all
mainstays I'm sure they don't know that
boy and the turns out it's like thinking
we can all shine bright like lightning
ways so I dunno almond okay you know
which are you thinking stay on track
many part of the racket record without
your CV and we are linked things start
they don't don't like away as it turns
out deciding it we can ask our right
[Music]
comic in red stain
huh making noise
[Music]